by the grace of Allah subhah wa taala
the response has been overwhelming to
say the very least alhamdulillah we've
had social media personalities and
respected Scholars sh from many parts of
the Muslim world promoting the cause we
have raised almost 1.4 million
alhamdulillah and we haven't been
sitting idy waiting to hit our Target of
2 million we have fully purchased four
properties in then transferred their
ownership to the W after the help of
Allah subhanahu wa tala none of this
would be possible without your support
so we thank you once again this is our
update to yourselves we encourage you to
stay tuned for more updates now that the
work alhamdulillah is truly
underway brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are well inshah as
you guys know the Western world is very
consistent they they they have the
Democracy they they they speak about
freedom of speech human rights advoc
kids they are leading the way they are
consistent when it comes to morality Al
yesb LGBT M you name it degeneracy His
Highest Elon Musk he bought Twitter and
then he said I'm going to put an x on
Twitter because I'm going to put the
past behind and let people who were
silenced to have a voice mhm uh what's
going on with that now uh it's
problematic because he's censoring loads
of people whoa whoa whoa what do you
mean censoring he uncensored people no
he's I think it seems that is he
censoring them to uncensor them uh I'm
going to say yes nice okay so what's he
doing we heard that he's demonetized and
taking the Blue Tick of four Accounts at
least four accounts they are not pro
Zionist accounts that's the thing bro
they are really yeah they're Pro
zionists no they're anti Zionist that's
what I said I said I'm sure they're not
pro Zionist accounts number one is pro
Zionist Laura Luma really she's there's
a picture of her with Donald Trump so
she also got demonetized she got
demonetized oh okay now that's
interesting why is that there must be a
reason cuz she's Pro zist there must be
something she's Pro that's anti it's
because initially Trump and the
followers of Trump have been
anti-immigration yeah that's why okay
however now Trump because some people
are saying because of the influence of
Elon Musk and other Tech Guys there's
like a Visa called the H1B Visa sounds
like a CO variant it maybe coron go
well it's going to affect a lot of
Indians apparently so one of the variant
apparently did allegedly come from there
okay so the H1B is a high skilled Visa
which allows you know for these
companies to get their workers in or
whatever the case may be but Elon Musk
was Pro the H1B visa and okay and was it
um Donald Trump has also now become Pro
even though he spoken negatively in the
past about it and he said stuff like we
don't want to take we don't want to take
these roles away from the American
citizens however now he's saying I've
always been for it and I think it's good
and this we know Trump obviously goes
back and forth a politician bro man yeah
but Elon Musk they they're really angry
with Elon Musk but what's interesting is
his reaction to these dissenting voices
because not not all of them are people
that have typically been against him
like Laura Luma is very prot Trump and
very you know Pro Republican Pro you
know that sort of side of things so
she's anti-immigrant she's completely
anti yeah so she's against Elon Musk cuz
he's an immigrant he was born in South
Africa well exactly and he probably came
raised and he probably come to the
country with that specific Rea no well
that's a very good point and uh so I
mean it's good that he's been consistent
because you got some people that are
born elsewhere like Donald Trump's wife
you know Ivanka Trump clearly not an
American citizen however send it back
you know what I mean
if you're anti-immigration then you know
send her back and try get one of these
American women exactly I don't think
that's a good idea a lot of people run
away from American woman the Western
woman sadly cuz they are not um
traditional so let me just get this
right he's he's banned myON gains he's
banned one doctor don't know her name
yeah Dr Lupin or lupus or something the
point is Anastasia lupus the the the
video Jack Shields yeah yeah exactly and
um Laura Luma and others so the the
point is this guys in this video what
we're trying to highlight is that the
Western world come to us and tell us
about democracy and freedom of speech
their values and how they're consistent
they're not consistent they use that
opportunistically to their benefit the
moment Elon Musk realized oh snap this
is not working against my agenda what
does he do demonetize and get rid of the
Blue Tick and Shadow ban so the question
is then what happened to freedom of
speech it doesn't exist why is the
Western world after this Disney laa land
like it doesn't exist absolute freedom
of speech doesn't work anywhere and you
can see the hypocrisy in France when it
comes to criticizing the Quran Islam
when it comes to different countries I
don't know if it was Sweden that guy
who's burnning the Quran but when it
comes to the Torah when it comes to
criticizing Jews when it comes to
criticizing Zionist it's a nogo so the
video what we want to do today was to
point out the hypocrisy that they seem
like the upholders of freedom of speech
but they don't it's up until it benefits
them or they see that this not benefit
them and that's the reason why when you
look at the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam is life they didn't want to go
against his message much they let him
just talk when they realized that people
are flocking to Islam this is working
that is when they said okay now we need
to put a stop to this and the same thing
applies in the western world because
kufur back then is the same kufur today
Islam in the western world not all
Western countries of course we can
freely give da we can freely talk about
Islam until the moment they realize that
us preaching bringing more people to
Islam and people are fling to Islam once
they realize this is having an impact
where they are seeing the projection of
the society that it could potentially
become a Muslim country that is where
they would draw the line and that is
where they will go against all of their
morality or morals or whatever it is for
that matter and believe me a time will
come where they will only arrest people
like myself God knows maybe even try to
attempt to kill us to stop The Message
of Islam this is the reason why they
cannot hold on to these um uh these
things that they uphold they try to say
okay yeah freedom of speech what
happened you know what happened to you
censoring people I thought the whole
platform was about uncensoring people I
thought you was Champion that this shows
us guys the reality I was reading
something about n Nicolo mavelli and in
there he's talking and his kind of point
of view is that you do whatever you can
to maintain power yes yeah and even if
it means you know dissenting voices
killing he obviously takes it to an
extreme and he's to the leaders of his
time do whatever that needs to be done
whether it's lying cheating stealing
killing to maintain power and just you
can give the impression to the people
that you're LW AB that you're uh not
even law abiding because you're setting
the rules but you're a good person and
you're following principles and this and
that because people go by appearances
and this is what this video is about
Edon musk is somebody that's been
talking about freedom of speech he's
used that to win over the right wing and
there's another perception that oh
there's Unity amongst their groups but
you will see that although Elon Musk has
significantly benefited from the right
wing you can't align practically with
everything of the right wing and in this
regard he disagreed with them and
because of that now they are going
against him and somebody like Elon Musk
can't now tolerate that because again
West is promoting individualism in
rather than collectivism and when you're
an island when it's all individualistic
I mean there's only there's only so much
that can be done you know what I mean
like this Mirage oh with the Republican
party and Democratic party it doesn't
work like that not everything is a
binary either blue or red that fits in
with either an Elon Musk is learning
this the hard way and now he can't
tolerate it and he is trying to you know
press the dissenting um people and well
it just goes to show it be interesting
what's happening I mean you guys
probably saw that Tesla truck exploding
from of Trump Tower yeah when it comes
to this sort of stuff consistency is not
something that you can expect from
manmade laws yeah this is not that you
can expect from political this is not
something you can expect from political
parties this is not what you can expect
from man-made systems consistency will
come from objective sources more
specifically from God Islam and this is
what we need to understand yes they may
have P pulled the wool over our eyes
with regards to these um you know Mirage
like human rights and democracy and this
and that uh we're seeing over here they
use freedom of speech anytime it's with
regards to stuff and people that go
against them when it comes to people
that are on their side it's not freedom
of speech it's hate speech